if you google
can banks individually create money out
of nothing
you'll get it it's the most downloaded
um
apparently academic paper in
in all the elsevier um academic journals
across all the various disciplines um
so made a bit of a splash when it came
out 2014 even the central banks then
came out bank of england oh yes banks
create money we knew that we knew that
well they knew that but they didn't
publicize it
so but let me tell you so this this
study
was essentially um going to a bank and
and saying well this has to be real so
i'm really going to borrow money
because the the three theories of
banking differ on that point when you
borrow money
where does this money come from so we're
going to go to the bank a really
functioning bank
we need access to their accounting
system and their
it essentially is all in the it isn't it
we need access to that which was a bit
of a big hurdle because that's all
high security isn't it customer data and
and so on
but for scientific research i managed to
to get that the bbc was actually filming
um
as well and
the question then is so does the bank
when the bank gives out a loan so i
really borrowed money it was 200 000
euros which would be what 250
000 or something and i i told the
bankers
well no i want to transfer this away to
my
own bank account at another bank it
needs to be you know i really need to
get the money
otherwise i don't want to some kind of
simulation or theoretical stuff
has to be real so they were quite
nervous about this like
is this a quite a got an elaborate scam
and this guy is just
gonna run with this money um
and so then we did this and the question
then was
when i get the money booked to my
account
um where does the bank get the money
from is it from um
from deposits customer deposits as the
financial intimidation theory claims
or is it from excess reserves let's say
at the central bank as the fractional
reserve theory says
because without excess reserves you
can't do the new lending or
is it just you know created out of
nothing out of thin
air invented and
well the conclusion was the money was
invented
the deposits didn't change the reserves
they didn't even check how much do we
have in reserves and
was was uh untouched
um and it was simply newly
credited to me now if you look at the
legal side for those who are interested
in this question
from the legal perspective it's actually
um
it's most clear it's you know clearly
visible what's what's going on
because what the bank really does is
when you
when you get a loan a mortgage whatever
the moment you sign the loan contract
that
can be considered and the bank does
consider it as
a promissory note that you've written in
other words it's security it's an iou
that you've issued as the borrower of
course
and you promised it's a promise to pay
you to repay this money
so really you've issued a security like
when the you know the government issues
treasuries you've issued your
your loan your mortgage treasury your
security okay
the bank now says okay we're gonna buy
that
and it puts it on its balance sheet as
an asset because now they have a claim
on you because you promise to repay this
money
and you say at this point actually i
don't care about these details just give
me the money
and if the banker is careful the banker
will say
you will find it in your account with us
they may carelessly say or we've
transferred it to your account that
would be technically wrong because no
transfer takes place
that's what i confirmed in that
empirical experiment
that when i got the money it was not
transferred from
any other account i mean you know you
can see where does it come from
and it didn't come from any other
account inside the bank or outside the
bank
so what is it well at law because the
bank has has
got your promissory note it also
according to the loan contract
owes you money as well right
that's the money that you want in the
first place that's why you went to the
bank for the loan
now that means there is an accounts
payable liability that the bank has
because you know it hasn't paid you but
it needs to pay you
and therefore on its liability side of
the balance sheet it will also record
the same amount that it's already
recorded as an asset
when it bought your iou say two hundred
thousand dollars
but they also owe you two hundred
thousand dollars and accounts payable
liability and now is the little trick
they will book this as a liability on
that balance sheet
but of a different category they won't
actually
say oh it's an accounts payable
liability arising from the loan contract
that's really the truth well it puts it
in plain english
yes exactly it puts in plain english
this other paper is called
how how do banks create money and why
can other firms not do the same you can
also google it as open access as well
and so what they do is they don't book
it as an accounts payable liability
which would be correct
they book it as a liability of another
type namely
a customer claim on the bank that they
call
a bank deposit because what is a bank
deposit it's a claim
by customers on the bank and this is an
english law well established
for centuries that there is no such
thing as a bank deposit
it that's not a legal concept doesn't
exist
all there is is a loan we've given to
the bank so deposits actually
loans that we've given to the bank and
that's what they put in their lot on
their liabilities well
we owe their money that's how we record
it now the bank's
record of the bank's debt to the public
that's what we call bank deposits and
that's our money supply
and so of course they can invent it out
of nothing so then suddenly when you
look at the legal side
it's not so magical or surprising that
of course they can create money because
really
they're just adding more liabilities
they have
and because the banking license gives
them the right
to put things on their balance sheet
accept deposits the banking license
really allows us to accept deposits
that means they can invent new
liabilities on themselves
which they do when they give out a loan
now of course the borrower has no idea
about
these details right and they think well
i've got money here because look i've
got it
in my um bank account current account
it's there
and i transferred to somebody else and
nobody realizes that that's just been
newly invented by the bank
on the back of the bank purchasing your
iou and as banks do more of that
the money supply expands and this is
where
actually now we're at the core question
because now come back to japan and the
capital flows and everything
so if banks
lend money they they create new money
they expand the money supply
and the key question now is what is this
money going to be used for
and this has a massive impact on
everything in the system
if banks were just financial
intermediaries it wouldn't really matter
that much
and it's true for for real non-bank
financial intermediaries whether
insurance companies or asset management
companies
it's money in here money out there
that's just shifting existing money that
doesn't have a macro
impact but we're talking about money
creators and the central bank only
creates three percent of the money
supply
it's the banks that create 97 of the
money supply
so therefore their decision of who gets
the money and how much money they get
and
what are they going to use the money for
that
reshapes the economic landscape in a
very short time period
now this the simplest way to analyze
this is essentially there's three
scenarios
if a bank creates new money
and it's used for
asset purchases then
what happens if the bank was a financial
intermediary
nothing much would happen because the
money is pulled out somewhere else
and it's shifted into assets it's a
shift
but when a bank prints new money because
that's what it is like money printing
bank credit creation bank lending and
the asset purchase takes place with
you know uh bank lending being the
source of funds
then you have created new money
injecting this new money into the real
estate market for example
you're going to push up real estate
prices and the same with asset prices
so when banks lend for asset purchases
you're pushing up asset prices that
explains the 1980s asset bubble
this is always unsustainable always